to lebanon now where after more than a
year in limbo the country has succeeded
in forming a government the president
brokered a deal after 13 months of
squabbling among political factions now
lebanon's richest man telecom's tycoon
najib mikati has been named prime
minister and he's no stranger to the job
najib makaki visits lebanon's president
to formalize the end of the political
limbo
the prime minister designate says he
hopes the new 24-member cabinet can
bring stability to a country engulfed in
economic crisis
we can all feel it the situation is very
difficult and we all know this but it's
not impossible to deal with if we
cooperate as lebanese we have to work
hand in hand our team will work as one
so that we stop this collapse and stop
the despair and we will work with hope
and determination
the billionaire businessman was chosen
to form a government back in july after
others failed
he's familiar with the position having
served as prime minister two times
before
and it's that familiarity that fuels
skepticism in the lebanese people
i don't think that this government will
come with solutions because it came up
with the same faces and mentality of
those who
but the lebanese people will not believe
in them since we have a long experience
with them they are the ones who turned
this country into ruins
a year without a government has been a
heavy burden for the people of lebanon
the currency has crashed leading to
critical shortages of food medicine and
petrol
the situation is really really difficult
i've been waiting here for an hour and a
half maybe they will still have petrol
by the time it's my turn maybe not the
situation is unbearable
the previous government resigned after
sustained public criticism following the
beirut port explosion leading to the
13-month quest to form a new government
parliamentary polls are due next year
with many pitting their hopes on the
ballot bringing in fresh blood
but others are doubtful of any results
that would change the status quo
you